it got me a little off guard
i was just notified about this 440 open
312.
where's pace we've searched top to
bottom and richard pace isn't here
hey
[Music]
let's roll
[Music]
you don't have to come with us
[Music]
[Applause]
the name's ringo that's violet oh man
wick over there
the con artist formerly known as prince
[Music]
let's cut to the chase here joey we got
the same piece of crap on our shoes
warner schultz it owns prisons in the
middle east
facility state of the art one of the
most modern prisons on earth
there's millions of dollars worth of
gold in one of those locations
we can try and stop that gold from
financing terrorism
steal their goal stop the terrorists
let's go to prison shall we
hope i only fly first class
[Music]
why isn't anyone saying anything
keep moving keep moving the only way
this is going to run smoothly
is if the prison isn't running smoothly
are you
aware of how many violations you have
going on here
keep pushing keep
[Applause]
you serious explosives i'm always
serious
total lockdown
i killed him this is not good
should we maybe call in the national
police are you high
catch me if you can
you